the gyro can experience now when you
train do you train to doing strongman
stuff like do you pull trucks and [ __ ]
like in training yeah so um leading up
to World Strongest Man I knew we had a
truck pole we actually got to pull the
the gravedigger in the Monster Jam fire
truck really on the the monster trucks
at Worlds this year which is pretty cool
how much the gravedigger way well so the
funny thing is it only weighs 15,000
pounds so they had to grab a second one
and attach them so we were hired two of
them at one time how does one ever say
it only weighs 15,000 pounds that's what
I want to know because I suck at that
event well I don't you know I would like
it if it was only one of them but that
sets an event where it must help to be
450 pounds huge huge advantage you know
you look at guys like me you know again
only five ten about to 85 competing
against in my qualifying corporate world
was Thor bjornsen the mountain from Game
of Thrones is how much Zach [ __ ] away
six nine four forty Jesus that [ __ ] has
a six pack six nine 440s so that's Thor
doing the event right there
and you can see gravedigger right behind
him and then behind that they attached
with a metal pole to the Monster Jam
oh so you use a rope to pull you as well
yeah so it's like kind of you get a
little bit of lever yeah there's a
second truck two trucks that is
ridiculous yeah so leading up to World
Strongest Man I actually became really
good friends with the firefighters in my
local town and I just I talked to the
fire chief I was like hey can I borrow
one of your trucks to [ __ ] fire breaks
out okay we got our friend he's out
there pulling it they can wait yeah
here's where his responses are you
[ __ ] me I was like I'm actually
serious so I actually I was pulling that
that was pulling that fire truck like
once or twice a week for like six weeks
leading up to world strongest how much
is a fire truck way um depends if the
water is in it or not I found that out
the first time it wasn't so it was only
about 28,000 pounds and it was actually
only 28 pounds casual that ain't [ __ ]
the second time the water was in it so
it was 40,000
oh no I was a little bit harder and it
made me look like an ass because like I
had told my friends that I was doing
this this time thinking that it was the
same truck and it was as light as it was
the first time I was like alright I'll
look pretty cool in front of everybody
and then I got to pull it I'm like this
is heavier yeah that's that's a lot
difícil it's an extra 12,000 [ __ ]
package yeah and so like I was training
at a 50 foot course and like that 40,000
pound truck who's taking me like almost
90 seconds to pull and that's like 90
seconds of just non-stop work Christ
what does that do to your knees the
knees aren't too bad honestly it's just
like a full body like burning like
everything hurts right
like nothing feel like your arms are
pumped because you're pulling on the
rope in front of you your quads and your
calves are just you know pumped to the
max at that point I'd be worried about
like knees and ankles
my biggest injury that you see with like
a truck pole is like the Achilles tendon
rupture right the Achilles tendon will
just like pop off when you're trying to
pull it that makes sense cuz you're just
pushing off with your foot pressure Oh
[ __ ] yeah god damn whatever sport is
really great it's a sadistic sport it's
just so crazy to watch people pull two
trucks like up a human being pulling two
trucks it's per pot I wish I would see
you with the fire truck that's that's
more ridiculous so you pulling a [ __ ]
fire truck it was pretty fun yeah sure
if you could do it yeah exactly we do
it's fun just that's a weird thing with
people right to just love to be able to
do something that's hard to do and I
think that's why like all of us are
attracted like strongman that's why we
compete yeah you know like like I said
in the beginning of the show like it's
we all have to be a little bit [ __ ] up
in the head to look at a truck and get
excited to pull it yeah look there it is
that's so crazy yeah I pull the truck
that's my coach behind it there yes yeah
have you ever seen the video of the
strongman who throws the barrel up it
hits the bar falls back and hits the
back of the head - that was on him is
that guy dead no he lived whoa yeah what
kind of a human can survive that I don't
know I think it was an empty cake that
makes it was even it was a [ __ ]
aluminum
all bouncing off your skull yeah yeah
yeah and he was knocked out cold for a
little while
[Applause]